I have a really really positive story to
tell you about uh that comes to us from
Keck Medical Center of USC which
announced that a team of doctors became
the first in California to inject an
experimental treatment made from stem
cells into the damaged cervical spine of
a recently paralyzed 21 year old man as
part of a clinical trial on March 6 just
before his 21st birthday
Chris bozan of Bakersfield suffered a
traumatic injury to his cervical spine
when his car fishtailed on a wet road
hit a tree and slammed into a telephone
pole and the parents Rodney and Annette
Bosen were warned that there was a good
chance that their son would be
permanently paralyzed from the neck down
however they also learned that Chris
could possibly qualify for a critical
study which might help and the leading
surgical team that was involved here uh
at the Rancho Los Amigos National
Rehabilitation Center actually injected
an experimental dose of ten million
cells they're called ast OPC one cells
directly into Chris's cervical spinal
cord in early April and this is just
unbelievable two weeks after surgery
Chris began to show signs of improvement
three months later he's able to feed
himself use his cell phone able to
operate a motorized wheelchair hug
friends and family improved sensation
and movement in arms and hands easier to
take care of himself
it's absolutely amazing and we are being
told there are some caveats here number
one for example uh this is not
necessarily something that would work on
people that have been paralyzed long ago
it does seem as though at least for the
time being this is something it's action
that needs to be taken uh quickly soon
after injury this is not something that
would work for everybody necessarily
many many questions around this but the
hope is there and what really is the
scariest and most disturbing thing to me
uh is that there are individuals who
don't want this type of research to be
done period there are individuals who
are against all stem-cell research
they're individuals who for religious
reasons it's sometimes the focus is on
embryonic stem cell
I know many people will say but David a
lot of these advances are not from
embryonic stem cell research it's just
from other stem cell research that's
true but how can we even measure how
much progress was lost under the Bush
administration when the embryonic stem
cell research was banned and it's great
that president obama has lifted that
it's great that we are moving on and
resuming that research but the idea that
the party that calls itself pro-life is
actually advocating against in many
cases research that would save people I
don't get it I don't know how you can
live with yourself I don't know how you
can say that you're the moral majority
it's very very disturbing to me